mich bewegt bewegen verschiedene krisen
des westens und
konkret habe ich ein buch geschrieben
dieses jahr jetzt mache ich den
werbeblock
global gescheitert der westen zwischen
anmaßung und selbsthass und da versuche
ich eine analyse warum auf der einen
seite
permanent eingeknickt wird nehmen wir
das beispiel winnetou das ist jetzt
nicht im buch aber darum geht es
letztendlich um cancelled wie kommt es
dass verlage das kulturinstitution
einknicken dass sie die kunstfreiheit
die meinungsfreiheit die
wissenschaftsfreiheit außer kraft setzen
nur weil einige aktivisten das fördern
was steht dahinter und meine antwort ist
da gibt es einen schuldkomplex der einen
so anfällig macht und wie hängt das
zusammen mit unserer fatalen politik
gegenüber russland und der ukraine mit
dem scheitern in afghanistan im
scheitern in mali und letztendlich ist
meine these die das wurzelt alles in
einer wahnsinnigen hybris des westens in
dem gefühl wir sind omnipräsent wir
haben ein gesellschaftssystem dass jeder
nur haben möchte wenn wir da die
geeigneten bedingungen schaffen
stichwort handelt durch verflechtung das
haben wir die ganze zeit russland
gegenüber getrieben und auf die andere
seite sind wir aber auch verantwortlich
für alles was schlecht läuft in der welt
das heißt für klimakatastrophe für
hungersnöte für kriege für
fluchtbewegung etc und das wird jetzt
diese art der negativen omnipotenz
fantasie die wird jetzt ausgenutzt für
aktivisten gesagt hier der westen ist
strukturell rassistisch die weiße haut
ist mit dem was ist und sozusagen
identifiziert und da kann man gar nicht
anders als rassistisch handeln es gibt
tatsächlich solche akteure die sagen
selbst die kinder von weißen werden
wieder rassisten werden weil das
unentrinnbar ist und ja dass die zwei
seiten von hybris die eine die ein
permanent in der welt auftreten lässt
als
personifizierung der demokratie und
dabei scheitert und auf der anderen
seite eben dieses dieser schuldkomplex
der die demokratie im innern aus wird
letztlich herr bruder der untertitel
heißt ja von dem buch der westen
zwischen anmaßungen selbst hasst ende
der auch für ihn stammen können
natürlich besser jetzt besser jetzt
wahrscheinlich schlechter als ja und
nein ich jetzt wahrscheinlich plakativer
formuliert haben verschulter werden dies
formuliert müssen sie mir noch eine
minute geben also ich würde ja gerne was
zu sagen ich mache also ich hab ich
durfte ja dieses prinzip kontakt schuld
jetzt im letzten halben jahr kennen
lernen also ich habe ja meine zdf job
dann nicht mehr und habe im februar hier
erzählt was mir widerfahren ist und ich
muss mir muss wirklich sagen ich mache
mir große sorgen um dieses land und um
die menschen die publizistisch tätig
sind die von dem meinungsportal der
davor gegeben ist abweichen und das ist
das thema kontakt schuld wenn ich mit
einem bunten alternativ medienmacher xy
interview macher dann leider nicht die
leitmedien nicht mehr ein aber das ist
ja nur die spitze des eisbergs was ich
schlimm finde und das habe ich selber
recherchiert es gibt allgemein mediziner
die haben masken attest ausgestellt oder
auch eine impf unfähigkeit bescheinigung
die werden zu hause auf dem weg ins bad
am frühen morgen von einem
sondereinsatzkommando der polizei
überfall wie ein schwerverbrecher wie
terroristen werden sie auf den boden
gedrückt fixiert und dann sagt ihnen
noch einer ins gesicht ich werde ihn
schon der werte hier schon was finden in
ihrer wohnung was wir in anhängen können
ja das ist einem doch der troll
brandenburg passiert der ist
allgemeinmediziner und publizist das
kann nicht sein dass wir das in diesem
land haben und das ist da hat die
kontakt schuld mit zu tun was ist weil
er gesagt hat dass wir hier in einem
faschistischen staat leben wenn sie eine
meinungsfreiheit haben davon gehen weite
teile der bevölkerung immer noch aus
dank unter anderem zdf und anderen
leitmedien das denken die ja immer noch
dann darf sowas nicht passieren oder
rolf krohn allgemeinmediziner aus
kaufering ein arzt der kinder die asthma
haben einen masken befreiungs attest
ausgestellt hat der hat mir kürzlich
persönlich erzählt dass es mehrere
hundert ärzte in deutschland gibt es aus
der verantwortung der ärztlichen
verantwortung heraus getan haben weil
das kind nicht mit maske im unterricht
sitzen kann
was passiert dem wurden die konten
geschlossen die immobilien abgenommen
mehrere hausdurchsuchungen zu hause und
das von der exekutive jesus staates das
kann nicht wahr sein und entschuldigung
wenn ich ein bisschen abschweifen aber
es hat für mich damit zu tun das ist für
mich das ende einer freien gesellschaft
und es findet in deutschland statt seit
circa zwei jahren das kann einfach nur
selber für die zuschauer die damals in
auftritt nicht hier erlebt haben sie
haben ja damals kann man schon sagen
auch darüber ausgepackt was sie im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk erlebt
haben und wo sie auch die
schwierigkeiten sehen in der
meinungsäußerung was ist ihnen denn
seitdem wieder fahren na also es hat
eine woche gedauert dann war man
wikipedia artikel gelöscht den hat meine
chefin anno dazumal 2008 angelegt als
ich das berlinale journal moderiert habe
also als ich zum ersten mal live als
moderatorin für 3sat vor die kamera trat
das ist das erste was passiert ist kann
man sich fragen ob gab es diskussionen
aber wikipedia artikel weg so erst dann
bekam ich einen verriss von einem
redakteur der faz auf meine person der
mit mir gesprochen hat ich habe aber
erstaunt und dann kam ein herr und über
medien ich meine das dürfen die alle
sind journalisten auch sie dürfen eine
freie meinung haben aber für einen guten
journalisten finde ich gehört es sich
dass er denjenigen oder diejenige anruft
also mich zum mörder werden ist ein
medium was damit geld verdient
eigentlich immer über kollegen zu
schreiben meistens negativ na ja da hat
man dicke maja ist eben mein jüngerer
freund von meiner ehemaligen haupt
redaktionsleiterin und auch wenn in
seinem artikel steht das zdf sagt dazu
nichts war an seinen äußerungen am
telefon relativ schnell klar also von
diesem herrn der das geschrieben hat
nein natürlich neves war rené martens
dass er natürlich mit irgendjemandem im
zdf gesprochen haben muss aber im
artikel steht dann prinz hätte er es
sagt nichts ist ja dann auch die
offizielle linie aber nur das ja nicht
jetzt so die erste mission mehr spitzen
ich glaube dass wir hier einen
geheimdienst haben der sich um solche
kandidaten kümmern die gegend großes
systeme die staats erhalten sind was tun
wenn man dann aber sozusagen das
öffentlich macht dann ist natürlich
schnell wahrscheinlich dass die frau
spinnt was ja schon auch der von den
über medien behauptet also ich kann nur
sagen es sind jetzt einfach so ein paar
punkte das ist aber alles die waren so
reaktion im privaten bereich weil das
ist ja meistens was einmal mehr mit sind
als wenn jetzt ein autor bei über medien
er war schreibt ist ja der meistens
weniger schlimm naja wenn man einen job
sucht und dann laut google die leute wer
hat sich denn da beworben also wie
gesagt ich hab jetzt ich bin da völlig
entspannt eigentlich aber das sind die
auswirkungen sie haben berge von akten
jetzt hat aber sie sagt kleinreden aber
banal bad auch privat kann ich nur sagen
dass also die die mich kennen und
schätzen alle gesagt haben danke dass du
das gemacht hast weil das war einfach
das was du erlebt hast ja da kann dich
jemand in die oder die ecke schieben
vollkommen egal aber das ist das was du
erlebt hast und du bist du wieder rechts
nach ultra extrem links sondern das ist
eine wahrheit gesagt und das hat mich
eigentlich bestärkt und ja was die
ehemaligen kollegen angeht da kam
einfach gar nichts bis auf ganz wenige
einheit den kontakt abgebrochen
aber ich glaube es gibt da so ein
kleines schweigekartell
lässt sie auch gar nicht mit ihnen in
kontakt treten ich glaube die schämen
sich ein bisschen weil kennen wir die
ganz große geschichte und man kann
natürlich in einem sommer auftritt nicht
alles erzählen vielleicht fanden sie es
unvollständig aber das sind jetzt
spekulationen also ich glaube das ist in
der natur der sache dass wenn man weiter
da arbeitet ist ja auch menschlich kann
es auch verstehen dass man dann erstmal
sagt hier was soll ich jetzt sagen wenn
wir sprechen würden dann müsste man ja
sagen dass man vielleicht gelästert hat
oder so also es gibt es gibt bestimmte
themen der
verdichtet sich das immer mehr daraufhin
dass es nur eine meinung geben kann und
ich kann mich erinnern als die alles
dichtmachen kampagne war von den
schauspielern die kritik an den corona
maßnahmen hatte da war sofort der
verdacht im raum dass ist rechts und
damit war rechtsradikal gemeint und das
kann man deshalb jetzt nicht ernst
nehmen heike makatsch hat sofort gesagt
okay ich mache da jetzt nicht mehr mit
wurde auch gefordert dass selbst tatort
star jan josef liefers nicht mehr der
tat und kommissars villa und einem
journalisten des öffentlich rechtlichen
institute gefordert dass er jetzt bitte
nicht mehr der tatort kommissar ist ja
und und es gibt andere themen auch da
es gibt wer sich der offiziellen
migrationspolitik kritisch äußert
gegenüber ist sofort recht sofort kriegt
ein abkommens kultur willkommenskultur
wer den begriff islamismus wie ich das
tue verwendet und sagt teile des islam
sind sie haben doch auch in ihrer uni
probleme erlebt ja absolut ich habe 2009
10 eine konferenz gemacht mit dem titel
das islamische kopftuch symbol der würde
oder der unterdrückung da hab ich dann
sehr unterschiedliche leute eingeladen
zwei davon auf dem podium mit kopftuch
meine assistentin mit kopftuch hat mit
moderiert aber es gab ihm vor im vorfeld
schon eine
internetaktion shitstorm der wurde
verlangt ich solle aus der universität
geschmissen werden also meinen job
verlieren das ist nicht passiert weil
sowohl die unileitung hinter mir stand
als auch der asta das ist aber eine
glückliche konstellation würde ich sagen
anders und sieht das nämlich völlig
anders aus aber dennoch hängt das immer
hinter hier also mir begegnet das ganz
häufig dass
ich irgendwo eingeladen werde und dann
gibt's alle gruppen sagt also diese
rassistin wollen wir hier nicht hören ja
warum rassist jetzt ja damals diese
konferenz hat auch bewiesen sie ist eine
anti muslimische rassistin
und das ist jetzt ein referenzpunkt
dafür und und so geht das also dass das
thema ist eines das nicht behandelt
werden kann jetzt kommen der rassismus
ja eine absolut entgrenzte definition
von rassismus was alles rassismus ist
wenn jemand gefragt wird woher man kommt
ist das ganz furchtbare rassismus der
verletzt andere zutiefst und das darf
nie wieder gesagt werden asche auf unser
haupt noch die runde herr bruder bei
ihnen das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
warum wollte er merz jetzt nicht auf
eine veranstaltung weil er angeblich
nicht wusste dass da auch ihr bruder es
wo sind ja streitpunkt mit herr merz ja
kann im gegenteil ich habe bis jetzt
verehrt wird ist die liebe erloschen und
dafür dass merz zuständig war hat er
wusste nicht dass sie zb auf diese
fragen anwalt steinhöfel und wir waren
eigentlich die die anschlusspunkte ich
weiß nicht warum man hat uns offenbar
zum rechten rand gerechnet ich meine
mainstream als ich und steinhofen kann
man gar nicht sein und ich denke ich
will dass selbst zugute halten ist ja
auch ein viel beschäftigter mann und mir
hat seinen pressesprecher auch
ausgetragen auch und das ist noch ein
anderer wird demnächst ausgetauscht und
viel ich weiss ich glaube der hat auf
seine berater gehört und die berater
sind zwei junge spunde 31 jahre alt und
für die ist eben alles was die nicht
sind ist rassismus dahin aber ist so
einfach ist es so einfach also ich habe
er zwar im märz noch eine kleine chance
geben er entschuldigt sich schick mir
einen baumkuchen vom café buchwald und
dann ist alles wieder gut ja aber ich
werde jetzt kurz nachgedacht um welchen
titel ich gewählt hätte das war
natürlich ein geklauter titel ich glaube
immer aber nur die besten ich hätte das
buch genannt der westen schafft sich ab
und ich hätte thilo sarrazin neuen
vorwort gebeten aber ich will noch ein
sagen darf ich eine halbe milliarde wir
haben in der bundesrepublik alles was
sie beschrieben haben kenne ich auch
nicht aus eigener erleben obwohl ich
auch schon gecancelt wurde aber das ist
jetzt nicht die frage ich kenne aus
meiner umgebung die geschichte mit den
ärzten habe ich genau so erlebt als ich
meinen bamberg eine geschichte
recherchiert dann ganz normale
praktizierende ärzte sind aus dem hut in
den computer bleibt mit er nahm an ihrer
dateien und sie wurden wie
schwerverbrecher behandelt später wurde
daraus nichts aber wir haben hier einen
tatbestand denn es nicht gibt es gibt in
der bundesrepublik ich weiß dass absolut
ein tatbestand der nicht existiert und
der heißt verfassungsschutz relevante
delegitimieren und des staates das gibt
es in keinem strafgesetz worin keine
strafprozessordnung diesen tatbestand
haben zwei koryphäen des rechtsstaates
erfunden und eingefüllt unserer
innenministerin daher seit mitte auf
allen ihren wegen frau phaser und herr
halte man glaube ich der chef des
verfassungsschutzes
verfassungsschutz relevante
delegitimierung des staates ist das ist
sozusagen niederschwellige kriminalität
dem strafgesetzbuch nicht erfasst ist
aber jetzt erfasst werden muss weil den
staat tod gefahr jeder mensch hat das
recht den staat beschissen zu finden und
auch darauf hinzuarbeiten dass der staat
ein anderer wird das macht die linke
genauso wie die bürgerlichen parteien
jeweils in werden sind aber ich kenne
keinen fall aus einer intakten
demokratie wo ein sub sub tatbestand
erschaffen wird kreiert wird aus dem
nichts geschöpft wird mit dem man dann
leute kriminalisieren kann die nichts
verbrochen haben dass apple wie ist denn
ihre meinung dazu zu der
meinungsfreiheit auch im journalismus
ist die gegeben wie sie das
aufmerksamkeit in unserem land
also ich kann nur für mich reden habe
ich ja schon gesagt und ich bin jetzt
seit 37 jahren in der ard und ich konnte
immer frei berichten ich hatte nie ein
problem damit mir hat niemand vorgegeben
was ich zu tun zu lassen habe nun
arbeite ich natürlich auch einem bereich
sehr speziell ist aber unabhängig davon
habe ich auch in anderen kollegen schon
nicht empfunden also mir geht's gut
vielleicht habe ich glück weiß ich nicht
aber ich kann das so nicht empfindlich
sich manche sachen
aber darüber haben haben wir schon vor
der sendung gesprochen dass ich mich
dazu nicht äußere nennen um zu solchen
dingen man das war auch klar verabredet
und jetzt mache ich auch nicht aber
trotzdem natürlich sehe ich
grundsätzlich
ist mit großer sorge in der gesellschaft
wie hat
links und rechts sich radikalisieren es
ist schon auffällig und sie ist auch mit
großer sorge wie wie wie intolerant man
mitunter miteinander umgeht das erlebe
ich auch natürlich aber eben meinen
privaten bereich und beobachtet das auch
mit sorge für meinen beruf kann ich das
nicht sagen also eigentlich seien alle
wieder miteinander reden egal ob naja
würden grundsätzlich mal findet alle
miteinander reden sollten also ich finde
die art und weise wie wir miteinander
kommunizieren
finde ich hat gelegentlich schlimm und
mein thema ist wenn ich seit jahren dass
ich sehe dass die sozialen medien die
sogenannten sozialen medien häufig sehr
unsozial sind und das etwas früher auf
am stammtisch diskutiert worden ist wird
heute halt in den sozialen medien
diskutiert bekommt dadurch eine viel
größere präsenz und manchmal würde ich
mir wünschen dass es lieber am
stammtisch bleiben würde was er
gelegentlich gesagt wird weil ich nicht
glaube dass es was hier vor noch gesagt
haben dass manche dinge die dann auch
angst natürlich ganz besonders eben auch
noch quasi multiplizieren wir ich habe
das gefühl dass wir gelegentlich eben
auch als medien uns überlegen sollten ob
er angst hat soviel vorschub leisten
oder sondern versuchen ab und zu mal ein
bisschen mäßigend einzuwirken
aber das sind halt auch eine beobachtung